wo ist dein weg
ich bin viel zu spät normalerweise bin
ich nicht so unglücklich aber nur diese
geht so der verkehr ist eine katastrophe
und ich war eine halbe stunde im stau
stau stau
das heißt es sind so viele autos auf den
straßen es geht alles sehr langsam micro
braucht ein zimmer ach ja eine wohnung
mit renovierter unsere heizung ist
kaputt und navina sebastian und ich
fahren übermorgen in urlaub das hostel
es sind keine zimmer mehr frei keine
zimmer
nein alle zimmer sind reserviert keine
chance
du bleibst du denn in deutschland
nicos tasche und sein passend immer noch
weg das ist wirklich ein problem post
belapan
ich habe doch platz der nette junge mann
kann gern ein paar tage bei mir wohnen
kommt einfach vorbei
hier ist meine adresse danke frau inge
mein lieber also bis morgen dann morgens